hey y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus so they
still got me locked in teener's Tower
and I've been snoring I uncovered some
truly wild y'all they got dogs
playing pogs frogs riding Hogs a plate
made of puke a date with a Luke amount
of dead mosquitoes a pound of red
Doritos a ping-pong paddle without a
handle a king's bong castle without a
candle Paul jamati riding a cube while
the hottest hotties smoking a Dube a
werewolf reading a rainbow a rare hook
eating a mango and y'all I found Michael
Strand eating a plate of his own by
candlelight I ain't getting out of
teener's tower alive y'all anyway y'all
are rocking out with dudes
dude poor Miley trapped in teener's
Tower with yeah
yeah well that'll happen with taffy
teeners